what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder it looks like the
Deadpool 3 trailer is coming during the
Super Bowl and it looks like they might
have a very specific plan for the
trailer to air during the Super Bowl
that is kind of brilliant but it's also
kind of trolling millions of people and
if what we are hearing is true it
involves not just one Cameo but quite a
few different cameos popping up in the
trailer but one specific Cameo might
push the trailer over the top to
literally break the internet we already
know that the trailer is going to shut
the internet down but if this one Cameo
appears it's game over and I think Ryan
Reynolds and the people over at Marvel
Studios have this in mind and it comes
from this description of the trailer
that we've heard today it also looks
like the trailer might show Deadpool and
Wolverine in an MCU spot that we have
seen pretty recently so we could quite
literally see Deadpool and Wolverine in
the actual MCU our main Universe in in
the trailer we will break down
everything you need to know in this
video and if you want to stay up to date
on Marvel and Deadpool 3 be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos we
are also doing a big giveaway more on
that at the end of the video so a lot of
people right now are talking about this
alleged leaked description of the
Deadpool 3 Super Bowl trailer keep in
mind the Super Bowl is only 8 days away
which means they are definitely working
on the trailer right now in fact they
are probably putting the final touches
to it although I'm sure they'll be
working on it till the very last second
but basically since we are so close to
its alleged release date during the
Super Bowl Marvel Studios has everything
locked down for what they want to show
and we know what happens when that
happens leaks start to come out people
talk then people start to share which is
how we are most likely getting this
leaked description now there are
actually two different descriptions they
work with each other but talk about
different things one was posted to
chu.com
dobr which I believe means Brazil and I
believe the language posted is
Portuguese but of course we have a
translated version of it and then
another one is coming from the geeky
cast a Twitter account online who post
leaks and updates and they state in the
Deadpool 3 trailer we get the void and
see the broken Fox letters it's a dark
tone now we've seen this in pretty much
all of the leaked photos from Deadpool 3
with the exceptions of the ones where
it's just Wolverine and Deadpool walking
down the dirt path together that Ryan
Reynolds released himself but as far as
the set photos are concerned most of the
set photos that we've seen take place at
the void and we have seen that broken
Fox logo 20th Century Fox logo the
letters in the background plenty of
times by now well the void is something
from the MCU the void was introduced in
Loki season 1 that is where the Citadel
at the end of time was where Kang the
conqueror's headquarters were and now
well Loki's headquarters aren't exactly
in the void because at the end we did
see Rana Ren slayer at the void and it's
clearly looking the same as it did in
Loki season 1 Loki simply created
another space and time for himself but
he did use the same Throne so that is
interesting but not the point of the
story the main point is that the void
exists inside the MCU and if we are
going to see Deadpool and Wolverine
there that means they will officially be
in the MCU so the trailer right away is
going to take Deadpool and Wolverine
from the fox universe and put them into
the MCU but according to the other
description that we're about to go over
it looks like Wolverine is actually the
one who grabs Deadpool and brings him
over a rough translation according to
Google Translate of the website of the
description posted in Portuguese says
this as a teaser the trailer will
naturally focus on Deadpool who's going
through a midlife crisis and has left
the life of Heroes behind he now Sells
Cars to support himself there is a quick
and striking appearance by Wolverine who
will stick his claws into his rival in
the preview Deadpool in turn gives Logan
nicknames making fun of of his hair
there is swearing and the rating is
definitely for adults furthermore other
mutants will show up wait to find out
who now there's two parts of this that
we need to break down but the one part
that a lot of people are talking about
right now is the other mutants will show
up wait to find out who and this is the
part that I was speaking of that might
break the internet for a few different
reasons one is that right away they
could just straight up start showing old
characters from the fox X-Men universes
I mean they could show Patrick Stewart
as Professor X we've already seen him in
plenty of interviews basically
confirming he is in this movie or at
least coming back for Avengers Secret
Wars we could see enan McKellen as
Magneto maybe Holly Berry as storm that
would certainly break the internet James
Marsden as Cyclops of course this would
be absolutely insane if they just right
away showed us them in the trailer
because there's two ways that they could
go with the advertising for Deadpool
three one is that they can just go all
out and straight up say hey it's a huge
Multiverse film we are combined find ing
the fox X-Men Universe with the MCU all
of these new and old characters are
going to be uniting together you're
going to see the old Fox Xmen and it's
going to be epic that's one way they
could go or the other way that they
could go with the marketing is basically
how they went with Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness they kind of just
tease the old Fox X-Men with the
Illuminati they never really showed us
them they simply mention the Illuminati
and we heard Patrick Stewart's voice but
we didn't really see a full glimpse of
the Illuminati until the movie happened
especially Mr fantastic but if the
subcription is real it sounds like what
they're doing is they're just going to
go full out and basically go yeah we're
doing this the old Xmen are coming to
the MCU this is a Multiverse movie it's
going to be epic get ready for it and
honestly I think that that is the way to
go I think that'll get people extremely
excited and I think it'll get people in
the theaters however there is one
particular Cameo that a lot of people
are talking about and that is Taylor
Swift possibly as dazzler now there have
been rumors that Taylor Swift is going
to be in Deadpool 3 for a pretty long
time now she is very close friends with
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively his wife
and in fact in Deadpool 2o you can see
Wade Wilson riding around in Professor
X's chair with a shirt on that is of
Taylor Swift's two cats Meredith and
Olivia so there was already a little
Taylor Swift Easter egg in Deadpool 2
but here's a reason why this would be
absolutely brilliant adding Taylor Swift
to the Deadpool 3 trailer the Deadpool 3
trailer that is going to air during the
Super Bowl a Super Bowl in which Taylor
Swift's boyfriend Travis Kelce is in
playing for Kansas City and he's
considered one of the greatest tight
ends of all time he's a nine-time pro
bowler and he's in the Super Bowl and
him and Taylor Swift have been getting a
lot of attention lately and a lot of
people have kind of been complaining
that Taylor Swift is typically shown
during his games on camera now in my
opinion she's really not shown that much
people just love to complain about
Taylor Swift all in all she's probably
shown for just a handful of seconds
every game I think they said that one
time during in a really boring game she
was shown for like 25 seconds or
something like that which really isn't a
lot Plus at Big sporting events they
typically do show the celebrities in the
stands and since Taylor Swift is dating
one of the players it makes sense to
show her but can you imagine what would
happen if they played the Deadpool 3
trailer during the Super Bowl and showed
Taylor Swift right now when she is
majorly associated with football because
of her boyfriend Travis Kelce the
internet would lose their minds Not only
would the swifties ab absolutely go
crazy but everybody would be talking
about this because they've already been
talking about Taylor Swift's face in
football right now this would be
absolutely crazy and the hype and the
Buzz for Deadpool 3 would go over the
top which I think is what Marvel Studios
wants right now they need it right now
so not that Deadpool 3 really needs it
because Deadpool and Wolverine appearing
in the same universe and then going to
the MCU is already enough to send Marvel
fans over the edge but if they're really
trying to go completely viral Ral
everywhere around the world then having
Taylor Swift in it is not a bad idea at
all I'm not saying they need it but it
would definitely add some views overall
I am really looking forward to seeing
what they do show us for the trailer I
do hope they show us some other mutants
I hope the marketing is hey we are going
to have some previous X-Men in this it's
going to be epic but let me know what
you think do you prefer them to show the
X-Men right away or would you like to be
kind of teased and wait till the movie
to actually see who's going to Cameo let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and let me know what
you think about the possibility of
Taylor Swift appearing in the trailer
please don't forget to like this video
And subscribe so you can stay up to date
on the MCU and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wol woof